hear what your boy said who my boy take  a listen  who else you want to play with  um in today's game  steph curry yeah  steph curry's the one that i want to  play with  oh [ __ ] the chef  you know what hey  he might want to play with you next  weekend now that is phenomenal when did  he say that was that on the shop yeah i  guess his latest one yeah  well he got it we got his wish so he's  the captain he's picked me the last two  uh all-star games so  i don't know if that suffices but  i'm good right now  how's that make you feel that right now  i mean whenever you get the uh  the interest or curiosity of what it  would be like to play with a  arguably you know mvp kind of caliber  dude like he is and  greatest of all time cool i guess  amazing right  we all can live in that fantasy world  though  you